bonjour à tous petite vidéo de réactions
à chaud à cet annonceur extraordinaire
qui vient d'être faite ce soir et qui va
être publié demain dans la revue
scientifique nature
on vient de découvrir une exoplanète
autour de l'étoile proxima du centaure
alors proxima du centaure ce n'est pas
n'importe quelle étoile c'est l'étoile
qui est la plus proche de nous après le
soleil évidemment elle est située à 4
années lumière c'est notre plus proche
voisine d'où cette exoplanète elle et
elle est aussi proche que possible et
alors cerise sur le gâteau il semblerait
que cette exoplanète elle est en plus
des caractéristiques qui pourraient la
rendre potentiellement habitables et
peut-être qu'elle pourrait abriter la
vie en tout cas elle aurait les
caractéristiques nécessaires pour
peut-être abriter deux au moins de l'eau
liquide et voilà exactement ce qu'il
faut en penser
alors cette planète qu'est ce qu'on en
sait sa masse déjà c'est une masse qui
est comparable à celle de la terre
puisque ce qu'on appelle sa masse
minimale c'est 1,3 fois la masse de la
terre donc vraiment de masse du même
ordre de grandeur que celle de la terre
et ça c'est très important parce que ça
indique que c'est très certainement une
planète rocheuse
il faut savoir qu'il ya deux grands
types de planète a notamment dans le
système solaire il ya les planètes
rocheuses mercure vénus la terre et mars
donc qui sont essentiellement fait deux
cailloux et puis il ya les planètes
gazeuses comme jupiter saturne uranus et
neptune qui sont faites de gaz et du
coup ces planètes l ont pas une surface
bien défini ces planètes gazeuses donc
c'est pas un endroit où on pourrait
aller se poser et construire un truc
pour ça il faut une planète rocheuse
alors le problème c'est que les planètes
gazeuses sont en général beaucoup plus
grosse et donc elles sont beaucoup plus
faciles à détecter que les planètes
rocheuses et donc pendant longtemps en
fait les premières des exoplanètes qu'on
avait détecté
c'était des planètes très grosse gazeuse
donc pas du tout adapté à l'idée je sais
pas moi d'aller les colonisés par
exemple depuis quelques temps on arrive
à détecter des planètes rocheuses donc
avec détails qui sont mettons entre une
et dix fois la taille de la terre et la
voilà là on a une planète rocheuse dont
la taille est du même ordre de grandeur
que que celle de la terre donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'assez
incroyable ce qu'on sait d'autre sur 7
sur cette planète c'est sa distance à
son étoile donc approximatif entorse et
une distance de 7 millions de kilomètres
alors sept millions de kilomètres en
fait c'est pas beaucoup un titre de
comparaison nous on est à 150 millions
de km du soleil
donc elle est vraiment proche de son
étoile et intuitivement comme ça on
pourrait penser que du coup sur cette
planète
ce doit être un peu la fournaise en fait
ce n'est pas le cas parce que il faut
savoir que proxima du centaure est une
étoile qui est beaucoup moins lumineuse
que le soleil
c'est ce qu'on appelle une naine rouge
et donc du coup quand on fait le bilan
on trouve que la température qui
pourrait régner à la surface de cette
planète
elle pourrait être du même ordre de
grandeur que la température qui règne
sur terre alors comment on fait pour
détecter une exoplanète comme ça et bien
pour détecter une planète de ce genre ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est pas
par observation directe c'est pas genre
pour un télescope sur les toiles et hop
on voit là on voit la plaine maintenance
pas comme ça que ça se passe
on fait une détection indirecte alors il
ya plusieurs manières de faire une
détection indirecte est celle qui a été
utilisée dans cette découverte c'est
celle qu'on appelle de la vitesse
radiale
alors pour comprendre ce que c'est en
fait il faut il faut voir que quand on a
une planète qui tourne autour d'une
étoile belle étoile elle bouge aussi un
petit peu parce que vous savez la force
de gravité elle agit dans les deux sens
c'est à dire que la planète exerce une
petite influence sur les toiles et en
fait c'est pas juste la planète qui
tourne autour de l'étoile c'est aussi
l'étoile qui peut avoir un petit
mouvement de rotation en fait autour du
centre de masse lui et du système et 7
légères oscillations de l'étoile on peut
la détecter alors c'est pareil on la
détecte pas directement ces parents là
c'est pas qu'on voit les toiles bouger
mais on la détecte avec ce qu'on appelle
l'effet doppler l'effet doppler vous
connaissez peut-être c'est ce qui se
passe quand on a une voiture de pompier
qui vient vers nous et que du coup on
entend le son de la sirène qui est
légèrement plus aigus puis une fois
qu'elle s'éloigne de nous le son est
légèrement plus grave c'est dû à la
compression et à la dilatation des ondes
sonores
ben il se passe à peu près la même chose
avec la lumière c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet doppler fizeau et notamment
quand vous avez une étoile qui est
légèrement en train de venir vers nous
sont le spectre de la lumière qu'elle
aimait se décale légèrement vers le bleu
et quand elle s'éloigne il se décale
légèrement vers le rouge
et donc quand une étoile est en train de
dos il est comme ça avec une petite
rotation on peut détecter ça en
observant le spectre de l'étoile en
savant la couleur de l'étoile et en
détectant des oscillations de sa couleur
et donc pour ça il faut utiliser un type
d'appareil qu'on appelle un spectromètre
qu'on me tombait sur un télescope et qui
permet de faire l'analyse de la lumière
alors je vais vous mettre une petite
courbe qui
très exactement ce que laisse que les
gens qui ont travaillé sur 7 sur cette
découverte ont vu alors c'est un exemple
de ce qu'on peut mesurer
il ya plusieurs choses intéressantes à
noter sur cette courbe la première chose
c'est donc ce qu'on voit là c'est le
l'évolution de la vitesse radiale de
l'étoile en fonction du temps et on voit
que les vitesses radiales qu'on mesure
elles sont vraiment tout petit c'est de
l'ordre de quelques mètres par seconde
donc c'est quand même assez incroyable
c'est à dire que là ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est qu'on arrive à
détecter des variations de vitesse de
l'ordre de quelques mètres par seconde
sur une étoile qui est quand même située
à 4 années lumière de nous
donc ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez spectaculaire et ce qu'on
voit c'est que l'oscillation vous voyez
que ça bouge mais ce n'est pas non plus
une oscillation hyper clair donc là ce
que je vous ai mis en rouge
c'est ce qu'on appelle le fit un cr
c'est une courbe qui a une oscillation
qui passe bien par les points vous voyez
que les données elles mêmes sont pas non
plus hyper hyper clair et en fait ça
montre que pour détecter ce genre de
choses il faut énormément de données là
je vous ai donné juste un petit un petit
extrait des données totales en fait il
faut il faut énormément de données pour
être sûr de la de l'oscillation convoi
est en fait les astronomes ont utilisé
des données qui provenaient de
différents télescopes et qui ont été
accumulées pendant 2 les 16 dernières
années ça a commencé en 2000 jusqu'en
jusqu'en 2016 est en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils ont été obligés
d'utiliser des données donc assez
hétérogène qui venaient de différents
télescopes qui ont été prises à
différents moments et analyse n'a lisant
ces données ils ont détecté cette espèce
de d'oscillations mais ce n'est pas
encore suffisamment sûre pour qu'ils
aient en gros le droit d'annoncer la
découverte de cette étoile et donc ils
ont fait au début de l'année 2016 une
nouvelle campagne de mesures vraiment
spécifique centrée sur cette question
qui a duré deux mois je crois et qui
leur a permis vraiment de prouver qu'ils
avaient vraiment cette cette oscillation
cette oscillation on voit sur sur la
courbe ici ça dure et c'est à peu près
onze jours vous ça veut dire que
l'étoile oscille avec une période de 11
jours et donc ça traduit le fait que la
planète tourne autour avec une période
de onze jours vous voyez que l'année sur
7 sur cette planète
en fait duré onze de nos jours à nous si
vous amuser à regarder la publication
scientifique vous verrez qu'il ya
énormément de personnes qui ont qui ont
collaboré pour
en arriver là et c'est notamment liée au
fait que je vous ai dit on a dû utiliser
plusieurs types de télescopes pour être
sûr vraiment de pouvoir confirmer cette
découverte est donc parmi les gens qui
sont qui sont dans les hauteurs de la
publication il ya notamment un français
qui travaillent au cnrs à montpellier
qui s'appelle julien maurin que je
remercie parce qu'il m'a envoyé quelques
petites infos au sujet de la découverte
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il ya
aussi d'autres personnes qui ont
travaillé sur sur les données liées à
cette planète et qui ont fait des
publications séparer notamment pour
essayer de comprendre qu'elle pouvait
être le climat qui avait sur cette
planète
alors qu'est ce qu'on entend quand on
dit que cette planète est peut-être
habitable déjà il ya une chose qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est qu'on se
focalise principalement sur l'idée de la
température mais pour juger si une
planète habitable ou pas il ya
évidemment pas que la température et à
l'atmosphère éventuellement la présence
ou pas de rayons uv de rayons x et c'est
quelque chose qu'ils peuvent être qu'ils
peuvent aller contre le fait qu'une
planète soit habitable
mais déjà on commence par regarder la
température est généralement considère
qu' il faut que la température soit de
l'ordre de grandeur de de ce qu'il faut
pour avoir de l'eau liquide ainsi on
part du principe que en gros lot liquide
est un peu un prérequis pour pour
abriter la vie même si ce n'est pas
forcément le cas j'en avais parlé dans
le temps d'une vidéo précédente
alors on peut essayer d'estimer le la
température qui règne sur cette planète
comment on fait on connaît sa distance à
l'étoile et on connaît aussi la
puissance de l'étoile à puissance
intrinsèque de l'étoile donc on peut
calculer en fait la quantité d'énergie
que cette planète reçoit et estimer ce
qu'on appelle sa température de corps
noir à la température de corps noir de
cette planète
c'est moins 40 degrés alors ça peut
paraître froid comme ça mais il faut
savoir que la température de corps noir
sait pas exactement la vraie température
à titre de comparaison la température de
corps noir de la terre c'est moins 18
degrés alors que la température moyenne
s'est à peu près 14 degrés en fait
l'écart entre les deux dans le cas de la
terre est due à l'effet de serre j'en
avais parlé dans ma vidéo sur le
réchauffement climatique c'est grâce à
l'effet de serre qu'en fait la
température qui règne n'est pas n'est
pas moins 18 degrés mais quelque chose
de plus important que ça et donc suivant
l'atmosphère qu'il peut y avoir sur
cette planète ou pas et la présence ou
pas d'un effet de serre il est possible
que la température soit supérieure à la
température de corps noir en tout cas
une température de corps noir de -40° on
considère que c'est pas mal parce que ça
c'est quelque chose qui serait a priori
dans la dans le la gamme qu'on recherche
pour avoir
tellement une planète habitable alors
comme toujours avec ce genre d'annoncé
il faut être un petit peu prudent alors
la découverte a priori en elle même
c'est du solide
il ya quand même plusieurs campagnes de
mesures qui ont été destinés a essayé de
recouper un peu les données pour être
sûr que ce qu'on avait là était vraiment
une exoplanète est notamment une
question c'était de savoir si cette
oscillation qu'on arrivait à mesurer
cette oscillation de 11 jours elles
n'étaient pas dus simplement à l'étoile
elle même et donc il ya des campagnes
spécifiques ont été faites pour
s'assurer que le nom
ce facteur là pouvait être écartée et
que donc c'était très très
vraisemblablement une exoplanète
par contre sur la question de
l'habitabilité bien évidemment faut être
prudent une chose déjà c'est que on
connaît la masse de la planète mais on
connaît pas sa taille ce qui veut dire
qu'on ne connaît pas encore vraiment sa
densité
donc on suppose que avec une taille
comme ça allait très certainement autre
chose mais on en n'est pas non plus sûr
à 100%
l'autre chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est qu'on parle de la masse de la
planète en fait si on regarde bien la
publication s'est pas vraiment sa masse
c'est ce qu'on appelle sa masse minimale
terre que l'estimation de la masse qu'on
fait en fait elle dépend de l'angle
d'inclinaison entre l'orbité de la
planète et notre notre ligne de visée
c'est à dire que la masse minimale qu'on
a qui a été calculée à 1,3 fois la masse
de la terre
ça suppose que la planète tourne dans un
plan qui est vraiment dans la ligne de
visée de l'étoile en fait si elle a une
orbite un peu inclinée sa masse réel
sera supérieure à la masse la masse
minimale qu'ont estimé
mais ce sera quand même probablement
dans les même ordre de grandeur alors en
conclusion bien personnellement je
trouve que cette découverte elle est
quand même assez extraordinaire
c'est vrai que les exoplanètes on entend
souvent parler bon ça fait 20 ans
un peu plus d'un an qu'on sait détecter
puisque la première exoplanète qui a été
découverte autour d'une étoile c'était
en 95 et aujourd'hui on en a détecté
plus de 3000 donc ça peut devenir un
petit peu banal
et puis c'est vrai que généralement
quand on nous en parle dans la presse
c'est plutôt pour nous annoncer les
trucs du genre où il a trouvé une
exoplanète avec deux soleils un peu
comme tatouine voilà bon moi j'étais
devenu un petit peu insensible à ce
genre de choses mais là je dois dire que
quand même je trouve ça je trouve ça
assez fascinant de se dire qu'il ya une
exoplanète autour de proxima du centaure
qui est l'étoile la plus proche de nous
à part le soleil et c'est fou de penser
que bon aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout
capable de faire du voyage stellaire et
je sais pas comment sera capable de le
faire mais de penser que le jour où on
saura faire le voyage stellaire ça sera
très probablement peut-être là la
première destination vers laquelle on
essaiera d'aller
et voilà cette cette planète elle vient
d'être découverte
et ben moi personnellement je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment enthousiasmant et
j'espère que ce sera la même chose pour
vous voilà merci à bientôt